wir gehen an den ort an dem in diesen
tagen geschichte spielt london
buckingham palace nach dem tod der queen
die vorbereitung dort für das große
begräbnis dass das live bild von dort
aus london große gäste werden erwartet
in den nächsten tagen sie kommen aus
aller welt und große gefühle schon jetzt
natürlich auf der letzten reise der
queen der sarg mit ihrem leichnam
eingetroffen mittlerweile in edinburgh
in schottland und kein meter dieser
reise ist die queen alleine immer unter
den augen ihres volkes ihrer menschen
und ihr sohn charles der neue king der
zeigt sich zum ersten mal als könig als
großbritanniens neuer könig in und vor
buckingham palace wir gehen nur zu
unserer bild reporterin kira ortmann die
diese trauer und die diese ganze ehre
die der queen noch einmal zu teil wird
begleitet aktuell in edinburgh ihrer
sagt uns einmal wie geht das jetzt
weiter was passiert dort heute
ja wir stehen hier vor dem palast
holyroodhouse das ist quasi der palast
der königlichen familie hier in
schottland und hier wird er sagt jetzt
entschuldigung seit gestern aufbewahrt
tatsächlich wird so heute seien heute
gegen nachmittag er gegen 3 uhr
deutscher zeit wird der palast und wir
gehen war immer diese meile lang will
der sack hier aus dem palast diese wohl
hochgetragen in die st james kirche und
dort wieder dann ab 18 uhr ungefähr
deutscher zeit 24 stunden lang für die
öffentlichkeit zugänglich sein so dass
ich das ganze volk aus schottland auch
noch mal wirklich persönlich quasi von
der queen und an dem sarg verabschieden
kann das war gestern tatsächlich auch
schon ein ganz ganz rührender moment
hier stand gestern alles voll mit leuten
und die menschen haben ihr zugewunken
bzw haben dem sag noch mal eben
gewürdigt und haben sich eben noch mal
ganz ruhig von ihr verabschiedet wir
haben erst damit gerechnet dass die
leute hier jubeln werden das ist ganz
viel dass es ganz laut wird aber das war
gar nicht so die menschen haben ihr er
nochmal in ruhe gedacht und haben eben
den moment noch einmal genossen weil du
hast gerade gesagt hier wird tatsächlich
gerade geschichte geschrieben und auch
prinz charles das muss man sich erst ein
bisschen dran gewöhnt dass man jetzt
nicht mehr prinz sagt sondern ebenfalls
er ist jetzt hier in edinburgh und wird
heute diese prozession hier von dem
palast in die kirche begleiten und das
erleben wir alle es heute mit dir mit
kira artmann unser bild reporterin eine
frage die immer wieder aufgaben in den
vergangenen tagen was ist denn jetzt mit
den hunden der queen was wird aus den
kombis mensch sind die jetzt völlig
allein das ist die antwort
[Musik]
elisabeth die zweite und ihre geliebten
korpys unzertrennlich von den 30er
jahren bis heute doch ihre aktuellen
lieblinge sind nun 100 weisen
die corgis natürlich eine britische
genauer eine walliser hunderasse
ursprünglich zum vieh hüten genutzt seit
den 30ern gehören pembroke welsh corgi
es bei den windsors zur familie mutig
und die pflicht sie gelten darum als die
britische aller hunderassen die queen
und ihre corgis mehr als 30 dieser
royalen vier pfoten hatte sie im laufe
ihres lebens an ihrer seite sogar ihre
eigene corgi variante hat die queen
gezüchtet eine mischung aus dackel und
corgi den doggy die queen findet in
ihren hunden geborgenheit und zuflucht
sie gehören zu ihrem leben und ihrem
alltag sind überall auch bei royalen
offiziellen anlässen
therapeut vom klub für britische
hütehunde weiß die situation für die
corgis einzuschätzen können wir in
dieser welt hat es tatsächlich geschafft
wirklich wie ein ganz normaler
hundehalter sich den hunden gegenüber zu
benehmen die es ihr mit liebe und
hingabe gedankt haben ihr leben lang
also sie hat sie gassi geführt selber
sie hat sie selber gefüttert selber
gebürstet und war ihnen tatsächlich eine
adäquate rudel führerin ihre hunde sind
nicht nur im privaten zu hause der
royals zu sehen wenn die königin reist
dann meist in gesellschaft ihrer hunde
im ausland bei öffentlichen terminen im
flugzeug und natürlich der legendäre
auftritt mit james bond darsteller
daniel craig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
2012 zur eröffnungsfeier der olympischen
spiele in london zeigen sich die queen
und ihre hunde in einem tv-spot
corgis die spitzen walisischen hütehunde
sind untrennbar mit der königin
verbunden sie liebt ihre hunde füttert
sie oft persönlich schlafen dürfen ihre
vierbeiner in einem eigenen zimmer doch
was bedeutet der tod der queen für ihre
geliebten hunde 400 stellen das pressen
manchmal ein versuchen immer wieder
bestimmte kleidungsstücke zu bekommen
und
die noch nach dem menschen nach den
verstorbenen menschen riechen aber
für diese cookies die da jetzt
vielleicht noch sind ist es so dass der
tagesablauf erstmal so weiter gehen wird
wie bisher nur eben dass ihre majestät
nicht mehr kommen wird trotzdem trauern
die tiere wenn ein geliebter mensch
stirbt wie ein mensch nur dass sie es
nicht sagen können und dass sie keine
tränen weinen so traurig der verlust
queen für die corgis ist die
werbeindustrie profitiert weiter davon
zum thronjubiläum werden 19
überdimensionale bunte exemplare in
london aufgestellt und dem königlichen
shop wird sogar ein paar vom vorrunde
ins sortiment aufgenommen
selbst wackel solar corgi es gibt es zu
kaufen was jetzt aus den hunden der
queen wird sie werden in der familie der
royals bleiben allerdings werden auch
die kleinen vierbeiner lange brauchen um
über den verlust ihres frauchens der
queen hinwegzukommen
aber wer passt da jetzt wirklich auf die
auf kira ortmann dort im buckingham
palace
genau wir sind hier in schottland und
tatsächlich wird es prinz andrew sein
prinz andrew und seine ex frau sarah
ferguson die jetzt erstmal auf die 30
rund 30 cookies von der queen aufpassen
und das ist tatsächlich recht
ungewöhnlich weil wir haben es gerade in
dem beitrag gesehen die corgis hat eine
so große bedeutung und natürlich hat
auch prinz andrew eine große bedeutung
aber dennoch ist er der skandal enkel
der queen und dementsprechend hat es vor
allem die britischen journalisten
gestern sehr gewundert als
herausgefunden wurde dass eben gerade
prinz andrew jetzt auf die cookies auf
passt ja ist ja auch nicht immer einfach
mit den hunden vielleicht späte rache
sozusagen muss die auf die hundehaufen
passen dank ihrer ortmann unsere bild
reporterin in edinburgh also dort wo man
heute abschied nehmen kann von der queen
auch king charles dort heute in erding
wirkt danke dir für den moment und die
trauer um die queen die lässt offenbar
auch alle streitereien vergessen oder
denn die brüder sind wieder vereins und
ihre frauen william und harry und kate
und mögen alle vier zusammen das sind
die bilder über die wir das ganze
wochenende diskutiert haben wie ehrlich
ist diese wiedervereinigung oder
möglicherweise nur von oben angeordnet
dieser befehl kam von ganz oben für
einen moment waren die fantastic four
wieder vereint seite an seite in trauer
verbunden zeigten sich william und kate
jetzt prinz und prinzessin von wales mit
prinz harry und herzogin medien am
wochenende vor dem schloss windsor um
der queen ihrer großmutter zu gedenken
mehr als 40 minuten verbrachten sie mit
den menschen spendeten trost namen
blumen entgegen und ehrten die crew
es ist das erste mal seit über zwei
jahren dass die vier zusammen in der
öffentlichkeit zu sehen sind und auch
wenn der anlass tief traurig ist so
zeigen diese bilder was sich rolf fans
seit jahren sehnlichst wünschen den
frieden zwischen den zwei brüdern
es ist total überraschend harry und
megan hier zu sehen es ist schön sie
alle zusammen zu sehen
ich denke es zieht einen schlussstrich
unter das was passiert ist auch aus
historischer sicht und es zeigt den
großen zusammenhalt der royalen familie
es war wunderschön dass sie heute zu
sehen waren
ich denke sie werden einfach alles unter
den teppich kehren und einfach wieder
brüder sein
doch wie kam es zu der lang erwarteten
wiedervereinigung vielleicht sogar einer
ersten versöhnung
britischen medien zufolge sollen sie
dafür verantwortlich sein prinz william
und könig charles
william soll harry und morgen persönlich
eingeladen haben gemeinsam mit ihm und
kate zu trauern eine geste ein kleines
friedensangebot dass harry und merken
wohl angenommen haben doch freiwillig
soll diese einladung nicht ausgesprochen
worden sein charles william angerufen
und ein machtwort gesprochen haben er
habe verlangt dass seine zerstrittenen
söhne ihren zwist nach dem tod der
großmutter wenigstens in der
öffentlichkeit beilegen und das mit
erfolg wie diese bilder beweisen
vielleicht bringt die gemeinsame trauer
die brüder auch in zukunft wieder näher
zusammen queen elizabeth hätte sich das
jedenfalls sehr gewünscht
[Musik]